est-ce qu'on fait la chenille dans les
mariages princiers
Charles et Camilla est-ce que vous avez
été invité oui est-ce que vous allez y
aller est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé à
la tenue que vous allez mettre oui je
vais mettre quelque chose que j'aime
dans mon cadrome petite robe bleue là
j'adore celle-là je l'adore
est-ce que quand on est prince on a le
droit de venir aux princesses on a le
droit de venir avec son caméscope non il
y a beaucoup des autres
et est-ce que vous pensez que Charles
avant de se marier va enterrer sa vie de
garçon
enterrer sa vie de garçon
se faire recoller les oreilles
se prend par la tête
toi qui a une carrière
vous connaissez les paroles c'est
comment c'est les paroles
3 4
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu